high security at laboratories handling
coronaviruses to stop accidental leaks
experimentation on samples tightly
controlled yet some scientists think the
virus behind Kovac 19 might have come
from a lab even though the prevailing
view is it occurred naturally a former
spy chief says the lab idea shouldn't be
dismissed as conspiracy it's an
engineered escapee from the Wuhan
Institute I'm not saying anything other
than the fact that the virus is the
consequence of you know gain function
experiments I mean I don't think a
particularly sinister sources from your
former place of work say but this idea
that the virus was manufactured in a lab
is just not credible I'm just staggered
they clearly haven't read the science
and I haven't attempted to understand it
because the onus is now on the
leadership of China to explain why the
theory and the hypothesis that it could
be engineered research by this scientist
and the chairman of a Norwegian vaccine
firm helped shape Sir Richard's view
they've published one paper despite
resistance but have yet been able to
publish a second I thought the whole
point of a scientific journal was he put
forward some speculation and you opened
it up to debate disagree what we won I
mean that's that's how you get to the
right answers
the first known victims of covert 19
were here in the Chinese city of Wuhan
it's widely thought the disease probably
descended from an animal virus most
likely in bats but there's no proof
about how it then jumped and adapted to
humans in a world where information can
be weaponized what should be a purely
scientific question has evolved into a
highly political one and what
gives you a high degree of confidence
that this originated from the Wuhan
institute of neurology I can't tell you
that I'm not allowed to tell you that
following the science will be key at
this new laboratory in Cambridge the man
in charge is dismissive of the lab
theory when we look at the epidemiology
of the virus what we know about the
sequence of the virus and the biological
properties that we're getting more and
more information it looks more and more
the existence of this lab in Wuhan that
worked on bat coronaviruses is seen by
some as more than just a coincidence but
the Institute of virology denies its to
blame for covert 19 Sky News has spoken
to four other scientists who caution
against dismissing the lab theory but
they're in the minority is crucial to
engage in debate in science but in the
end if one doesn't see many publications
in favor of a certain theory one has to
conclude that that's because there isn't
robust evidence in favor of that theory
perhaps so but it won't stop those who
think the lab theory is right from
wanting to be heard
Deborah Haynes Sky News